foreign
hi everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel our topic for today is
Tableau full course in this full course
we will be covering a brief introduction
to Tableau then we begin with the
Tableau tutorial later we will
understand the functions in Tableau
advancing ahead we will learn the
parameters in Tableau we will learn how
to get connected with data hi next we
will understand the LOD expressions in
Tableau after loading Expressions we
will dive into the data blending in
taboo we will be covering once we are
done with fundamentals we will get
started with charts in Tableau later we
will learn to design a dashboard in
Tableau once we are done with charts and
dashboards we will get started with some
projects in tablets data finally we will
go through some important interview
questions in tableau hope you are good
with the agenda for today's discussion
now let us begin with the session
so what is w
so before we understand what exactly a
stable you let us imagine a simple
situation imagine that you are an office
worker and you get some loads of data
maybe like millions of rows or billions
of rows and you are supposed to extract
the insights of that particular data so
what do you do you basically load that
data into a database and try to write
the SQL commands and then try to extract
the insights of that particular data
so this kind of approach is basically
time consuming and you get exhausted now
what if you had a tool which could write
all the SQL commands for you in the
background and all you had to do is just
to drag and drop the data
sounds interesting right
so Tableau is just the same all you have
to do is just drag and drop the data and
it will automatically write all the SQL
commands you ever wanted to write on
that particular data and it will give
you live data interactions and advices
for the future
now with this let us understand the
definition of w so basically Tableau is
a business and analytical software tool
developed in America W helps people to
understand visualize and make data
driven decisions in real time with
extreme agility and accuracy
now with this let us continue with the
next topic which will be about the
various versions of w so at first we
have the Tableau desktop so Tableau
desktop is a data visualization
application to facilitate you to examine
virtually any kind of structured data
and generate highly interactive
beautiful graphs dashboards and reports
within minutes once a quick installation
you can tie to virtually any data source
from spreadsheets to data warehouses and
display information in several graphic
perspectives designed to be easy to
utilize you'll be working more rapidly
than ever before next we have the W
server it is a business intelligence
application that offers browser-based
analytics anyone can utilize it is a
rapid fire alternative to the slow pace
of traditional business intelligence
software it is an online solution meant
for sharing Distributing and
collaborating on content created and W
what makes W different it is proposed to
everyone there is is no scripting
required so everyone can grow to be an
analytics expert you can grow your
deployment as you require it
train online for free find answers and
minutes and not in months that's the
specialty of w
now followed by the W server we have W
online
so Tableau online is a business
intelligence application that offers
browser-based analytics anyone can
utilize as discussed before it is a
rapid fire alternative to slow paced
additional business intelligence
software so Tableau online is a secure
cloud-based solution for sharing and
collaborating on Tableau view views and
dashboards next up we have the Tableau
public
so now I want to give you guys a serious
heads up if you are a beginner in W
public is like an open source whatever
the data you choose to work on using
table Republic it goes to public so kind
of like w public is not preferable if
you want to work on your company's
sensitive and confidential data W public
is a free software to facilitate anyone
to get connected to a spreadsheet or a
file and create interactive data
visualizations for the web
it is delivered as a service that
permits the user to be up to and running
overnight with table Republic users can
construct amazing interactive visuals
and publish them quickly without the
help of programmers or ID
it is designed for organizations to
facilitate their websites with
interactive data visualizations there
are higher limits on the size of data
you can work with and among other
features you can keep your underlying
data hidden and lastly we have W reader
wreader is a free desktop application
that you can use to open and interact
with data visualizations built in
Tableau desktop web tab new reader you
can filter drill down and discover
humongous loads of data now moving ahead
we have the features of w
so these are the few important features
that you might want to consider
those are the first one robust security
table you take special care of data and
user security it has a foolproof
Security based authentication and
permission systems for data connections
and user success
W also gives you the freedom to
integrate with other security protocols
such as active directory Kerberos Etc an
important point to note here is that the
W practices low level filtering which
helps in keeping the data secure
followed by that we have the
collaboration and sharing feature tably
provides convenient options to
collaborate with other users and
instantly share data in the form of
visualizations sheets dashboards Etc in
real time it allows you to securely
share data from various data sources
such as on-premise on-cloud hybrid Etc
instant and easy collaboration and data
sharing helps in getting quick reviews
or feedback on data leading to a better
overall analysis of it another extremely
useful feature of Tableau is the use of
Time series and forecasting easy
creation of trend lines and forecasting
is possible due to tablets powerful
back-end and dynamic front-end you can
easily get data predictions such as a
forecast or a trend line by simply
selecting some options and drag and drop
operations using your concerned fields
next up we have live and in-memory data
Tableau ensures connectivity with both
live data sources and data extraction
from external sources as in memory data
this gives the user the flexibility to
use the data from more than one type of
data source without any restrictions you
can use data directly from data source
by establishing Library connections or
keep that data in memory by extracting
data from a data source as per their
requirement
W provides additional features to
support data connectivity such as an
automatic extract refreshes notifying
the user upon live connection fail Etc
next we have informative View and even
the mobile view one of the key features
of Tableau and the one that got its
popularity is its wide range of
visualizations in W you can make
visualizations such as bar chart pie
chart Gantt chart bullet chart motion
chart tree map box plot and many more
like you name it w got it you can select
and create any kind of visualizations
easily by selecting the visualization
type from the show me tab apart from
that it is capable to represent data in
mobile view as well W acknowledges the
importance of mobile phones in today's
world and provides the mobile versions
of Tableau app the next and the last
feature is that being capable of
accessing data from various kinds of
data sources W offers a wide range of
data source options where you can get
connected and fetch data from data
sources ranging from on-premise files
spreadsheets relational databases
non-relational databases online cloud
data for data warehouses and many more
so followed by the features now we'll
discuss about the advantages of w
so following are the advantages of using
Tableau first one it has remarkable
visualization capabilities of course the
unparalleled capabilities of visualizing
information is on top of the list of tab
values software benefits followed by
that we have the ease of use the tools
intuitive manner of creating graphics
and a user-friendly interface allows
non-developers to utilize the basic apps
functionalities to the fullest users
arrange raw data into catchy diagrams in
a drag and drop way which facilitates
information analyzing and eliminates the
need for the help of IT department and
patent building
next high performance apart from its
high visualization functionality users
rates its overall performance as robust
and reliable the tool also operates fast
on big data which makes it powerful
performance on an important point on the
list of the advantages of tablet and
next is the mobile friendliness one of
our best advantages are the W benefits
is its efficient mobile application
which is available for both IOS and
Android it adds Mobility to table users
and allows them to keep statistics at
their fingertips as well as supports
their functionality that desktop and
online versions have
and finally we have a thriving community
and Forum W has a rich Community the
number of w fans who invest their
expertise and skills in the community is
increasing rapidly business users can
beef up their knowledge on data
processing and Reporting and get many
useful insights in this community also
Forum visitors are ready to help settle
any user issues and also share their
experience
next up we have the disadvantages of w
the first major disadvantage is the high
cost the Tableau is not the most
expensive visualization software
especially compared to such business
intelligence such as oracles and IBM
Solutions all the same the license is
quite costly for small and medium
companies which makes it one of the
considerable fabulous disadvantages
next is the inflexible pricing W sales
team is not flexible enough to provide
case-by-case approach for their
customers ignoring the fact that each
company has its own a unique
requirements for visualization tool
package the Tableau sales model requires
clients to purchase and extends license
from the start
as a result a lot of companies that you
establu arrive at the conclusion that
they don't need all their license
features they would prefer to buying a
set of required months and scale them if
necessary
followed by that the next disadvantage
is for after sales support on multiple
message boards users complain that W
software lacks proper after sales
maintenance if customer has software
performance problem the support team
does not settle the matter by
investigating the problems root and
eliminating it next we have the power bi
capability or the poor business
intelligence capability as previously
mentioned the tool provides
best-in-class information visual
interpretation however it lacks the
functionality required for a fully
fledged business intelligence tool such
as large scale reporting the building of
data tables and statistics layouts and
lastly the poor versioning only the
recent Tableau version support revision
history while for the older ones
software rolling back is impossible now
with the advantages and disadvantages
discussed let's move into the top
companies hiring the companies which are
desperately looking for Tableau experts
are Accenture ey PepsiCo Deloitte Wells
Fargo capgemini and many more
now let's discuss the humongous and
handsome salaries offered by this Tech
Giants
so according to Glassdoor the average
salary of a tableau expert in America is
82 000 grants and for a beginner it is
somewhere around sixty thousand dollars
per annum and at the highest rate it is
one lakh ten thousand dollars per annum
similarly the average salary of a
tableau expert in India is 5 lakhs 6000
per annum and for a beginner it is
somewhere around Three lakh Sixty
thousand and and for a highly skilled
experienced Tableau expert the salaries
range from 8 lakh seventy five thousand
per annum here's a story
when comments on how the IPL cricket
league was very entertaining this year
and how he believes that de Villiers
scored the max maximum runs but the
second gentleman says he has stats which
shows that Kohli outperformed this time
how did you come up with these stats
there's a tool that helps visualize data
by creating interactive charts and
graphs it's basically a business
intelligence tool used by many
organizations for visual data analysis
Tableau helps us gain insights by
visualizing the data that you already
have so Tableau is important when it
comes to visualization it has many
advantages first it has speed of
analysis so you can get into your data
and start analyzing it very quickly
second it helps users be self-reliant
and not rely on very difficult analytics
tools to start digging into their data
third it allows you to do visual
Discovery so as you're building you can
learn information and insights about
your data four you can use it to blend
diverse data sets and five you can use
the data sets that are centralized so
after you've put together a data set you
can publish it out and more people can
use it than just you that sounds
interesting how about we visually show
the stats of IPL so first we'll look at
connecting to data this will be the
first step in tableau
so if you've opened up your workbook and
you see this page you can click here
connect to data
and we're going to choose a text file
and we're going to join our deliveries
data
to
our matches data so when we click
deliveries it brought in deliveries and
we can click add and bring in another
text file called matches
next we'll talk about joins we will make
use of joins when we have multiple data
sets to work with suppose we want to
join these two data sets one of which
has a team ID and what city that team is
in the other one has a team ID and tells
you the name of the team there are four
ways to join data sets and inner join
the resulting table contains values that
have matches in both tables so we can
see here that we have Delhi and the
Delhi Daredevils we also have tonight
and tonight Super Kings we have
Bangalore and then we have this team
that doesn't exist in Bangalore and so
since these two don't match since we
have two two three three but then we
have four and six these two don't exist
in our resulting table because they
don't have matches in both tables in a
left join resulting table contains all
values from the left table and the
corresponding matches from the right
table so we have Delhi Chennai and
Bangalore and then we have their matches
however Bangalore does not have a match
so it was left no in a right join we
have the opposite the resulting table
contains all matches from the right
table and the corresponding matches from
the left table so we have the Daredevils
the Super King and then we have King
Punjab and they all exist however number
six does not have a corresponding City
and so that's left null and in a full
outer join the resulting table contains
all values from both tables so we still
have Deli in tonight and we have
Bangalore and we have the Kings but
they're nulls their corresponding nulls
exist as well so since this one doesn't
have a match it still shows up but you
get a null and then this one doesn't
have a match it also still shows up and
you get a null
now it's going to allow us to join our
two different data files and together
so we have to decide which field to join
on in this case it is match ID
and then on the matches it's just called
ID
not is ID
we'll do an inner join that will select
only the records that match between the
two Fields so it's given us some
sample data underneath from our two
things and we look at match ID here and
where it's one
here
we'll scroll over and see that it's one
here for ID
if we scroll down and find a different
number so here we have two Freddie and
we scroll over and match ID is now two
and we have our join in place
dimensions and measures dimensions are
qualitative fields that cannot be
aggregated for example batsman and
batting team
Etc however measures are numerical
values that mathematical functions can
work on like batsman runs and Extras so
for the case of batsman runs you can sum
up all of the runs for an entire game or
that took place in a city or for an
individual batsman and that's how you
can tell that it works with a
mathematical function now we'll move on
to the last part of dashboard designing
so we can move on to sheet1
I will take a second and load our query
and now we have
the
worksheet space and this is where we can
build our visualization this is called a
worksheet you can also build a dashboard
which is where you can put multiple
worksheets together
and you can build what's called a story
which is where you can take worksheets
and dashboards and put them in an order
to tell a story
so on our worksheet
we'll have this space here in the middle
which is where you can build the
visualization you have columns and rows
where you can drag on your data which is
here on the left here's our data
dimensions on top measures on bottom
we'll talk a little bit more about that
in a second we have columns and rows
where you can drag your information and
it defines where the columns go or where
the data goes to define the columns
where the data goes to define the rows
we have places here these are our cards
and when you drag things onto these
different cards it will do different
things to your visualization
and let's talk about our dimensions and
measures so Tableau will take its best
guess
at what your data is so it's guessed
that all of these blue fields on the top
are dimensions
and dimensions are
qualitative data so data that defines
and like describes the rest of your data
and so
usually it can be things like City so
you can say here's a city and then we
can look at our
different
measures by the city that it took place
in for the example with financial data
you could pull on City and you could
look at sales by City And city is the
dimension which is a quality and then
sales would be a measure which is
something that is quantitative and it is
able to be aggregated
whereas dimensions are not things you
would like to aggregate so some things
can be
a number but they're still not a measure
such as a phone number nobody is going
to want to sum up different people's
phone numbers and see what the sum of
the phone number is however you might
want to look at a customer and see their
phone number
and puts it up in the dimension area
another thing that Tableau does in this
case by default it will make little
folders for your different data sources
so we have our deliveries data source
and our matches data source
if we go back to our data source section
that corresponds
to our two different files you can also
look at these sample Fields here and the
part where it's blue at the top
represents the blue table if we keep
dragging we'll see the orange coming in
which represents the orange table
so here we are back at sheet1
and let's start building our first
visualization
I'm going to right click here click
rename and we're going to call it
matches in each venue
so we're going to start off by making a
map
Tableau has recognized the word City
here and put this little Globe next to
it meaning that it has recognized it as
having the geographic role of City
so if I double click on it
it Maps out
some cities now I was having a hard time
mapping the cities so we're going to
click edit location
and it doesn't recognize these places or
it could exist in multiple places
because it's defaulted the country to
the United States
so if we change that defaulted country
to India
then
we have much fewer unknown
Fields so we're going to focus on India
and
not look at these other
locations because some of these are not
in India and but we're going to make
this visualization for India
specifically if you wanted to show what
countries they were in you can Define
from what field you can find the country
information so if we had two fields in
here one was City and one was country
that told you what country it was then
you would choose this from field and
you'd choose that country
dimension
and that would fix our problem assuming
things were spelled right and put in the
right countries in this case we don't
have country so we have defined India
and that's what we're going to focus
next we're going to bring City
onto color as well
and now they each have their own colors
and here's our Legend
and we want these to have a different
size based on how many matches they've
had
so we're going to bring on ID
onto size
and
we
wanted to actually count
those IDs so we changed it to account
distinct and now you can see the
littlest ones have around two and as
they get bigger this to this size is 20
and this size is 85 and when you hover
you can see exactly how many they have
you can adjust the size using this size
marks card
make our circles a little bit bigger
we can adjust our color
by adding a border
maybe like a black border
but then changing the opacity
so we can see through it a little bit
for those that go over borders
and start to overlap
and if we wanted to see the exact number
without having to hover we could take
this ID onto label
and again
change it to count distinct
there we go
and now you can see exactly how many
there are in each location
you can change where the labels show up
by adjusting the alignment so we could
have it in the center and it kind of
shows up inside their circles but it's
kind of hard to read in these smaller
circles so we could Define that we
always wanted at the top
or something like that
we could also have it say The city name
so if I drag City on the label
now it shows nine and then the city but
if I want to change the order of that
see how it does the count and then the
city
I could drag so you saw right inside of
here we have two that are on labels so
they have this little T inside of a box
and now city is on top
of ID so City and account
we could also allow
people to filter
so if we click show filter here
and if we just want to look it'll zoom
in on the countries you select so if we
just wanted to look at a couple of them
then we could select individual ones
or if we wanted to exclude certain ones
then we can make it easy to exclude
great so now we have our visualization
for matches in each venue next we're
going to make another
worksheet by clicking down here and
we're going to name this one
top
run scores
and this will allow us to be able to
find who scores the top runs and so
we're going to make
a visualization
called a tree map
using this show me button we have an
explored show me yet show me will show
you what visualizations you can build
based on what you've selected
over here so when we selected City it
shows us that we can make Maps using
City what we're going to do
is look at
City
and
I'm going to hold Ctrl
and click batsman and I'm going to hold
Ctrl and click batsman run
and now you can see that tree map is
highlight is filled in not grayed out
anymore so we can select that
and it is showing us
what batsman have the most runs we want
the color to be based on city so let's
drag City onto color
and now we can see that it's separated
out by City
and you can see that the person
at the very top right with the biggest
square has the most runs but then you
also get a second benefit of being able
to know which city seems to have the
most runs associated with it so it looks
like Mumbai
has the most runs
let's also filter this information so
let's bring on
batsman runs and we can choose some
and let's filter out batsman who didn't
get
a total of
400 runs
there we go so now we only see batsman
and cities that have a sum bigger than
400 runs okay so we have City on label
but maybe we just want to be able to see
that on Hover so we'll take City off of
label and now we just see the batsmen
who have the highest runs for each City
and
we'll also bring on
the number of runs onto label so now we
can see the batsman in their runs and
exactly how many
runs they have
you can always get to how many they have
based on Hover
we'll go on to our next visualization
and that's going to be
win percent
based on toss
position
so we're going to see
which decision you make based on the
toss
leads to a win more often so you can
choose to bat or you can choose to field
and if you choose to bad do you win more
than if you choose to fail so let's take
a look
we have our toss decision
and we also have
if they won the match or not match
winner
I'm going to control click toss decision
and we're going to select pi
so here we have a pie chart that colors
it based on toss decision which is bat
and field
and makes the angle and the size of the
circle based on the match winners now
we're only going to have the
angle be based on Match winner or not
and then we can Define the size
ourselves so we can make it bigger
I'm going to change this visualization
to fit the entire view so that we can
see the pi better
great but we don't see a percentage so
let's change this sum of match winners
to a table calculation so we're going to
click add table calculation
and we're going to change it to percent
of total
what goes that so now when we hover it
says 60 of the matches were one
by the people who chose filled
and 39 were won by the people who chose
bad
let's make this into a label as well so
I'm going to control drag toss decision
onto label and what that does is make a
copy
and add it to label instead of pulling
it off of color so let's see what
happens if I don't hold Ctrl so if I
just drag toss decision on the label it
got rid of it off of color and just put
it on the label and that's confusing
there's two pieces but they don't look
any different
so control drag fixes that we'll do the
same thing for that
match percent of total that we made
match win percent of total
one of the benefits of having these
labels here
is that it allows you to be able to use
this visualization even if you take a
screenshot and send it to somebody and
they can't hover over the top and see
what everything means another thing you
can do
is annotated and so we can click
annotate the point or the mark
and it will give you this box and then
it will put in some information that's
showing up in your your tooltip and you
can modify this and
we can change this so it's not bold
anymore or leave it bold and when you
hit OK
it is makes this box that you can move
tells you information about the that
point or that Mark
when you do the same thing here
and draws a line
and this allows you to
put notes about it you can see that
these parts
are Dynamic so it just fills in toss
decision based on your field from over
here and it will change if it changes so
will the percent match winner
so for example this is for everybody
over all time
but if we show a filter
for City it adds it to our filters card
up here and then we could filter it to
just
this city and you can see that they have
updated
and
in this city
they have more people who have chosen
to bat win the game
and so you don't end up with
old static information in either place
but if you did want to make a note
manually about what you think is
happening here
then you can do that as well
we could also do the same thing with
date
and now you could choose just what year
you want to see so just 2017.
and in 2017 the field advantage was a
lot higher
and here's 2016.
and that's all time our next
visualization is going to
explore the idea of if you win the toss
How likely you are to win the game
so we're going to look at historical
data and see what's happened in the past
so we're going to call this advantage
of toss winning
so we're going to bring on
all of the toss winning
teams
and we're going to
also bring on all of the
teams that actually want so
how it works
is we can see all the teams and you can
see if they won or not so we're going to
quickly make a couple of changes to this
the first one is
this team
changed its name to this team name so
we're going to group those two teams
into the same group so that they are
treated like just one
and we're going to create a group based
off of winner
and we're going to grab the two team
names by control clicking and click
group
and it puts them together
let's replace winner with our winner
group
there we go so now you can see
those two teams are together
do the same thing with toss winner
create group
one disadvantage to creating a group is
that it's very manual
and so
you have to manually create the group
and you have to manually update it so if
they change their name again you have to
change it again and
it's nice to have the functionality in
Tableau to make those changes in case
you don't have the functionality to make
the changes to the data source itself
but do keep in mind if you have to
manually group things together you have
to manually keep it updated as well
next we're going to exclude some data so
we have this null here that we'll just
click exclude on because that would be
perhaps when a winner was not declared
and we're going to remove some of these
teams that have holes in their analysis
and that could happen because they
didn't play all of the teams or so there
was never a match with that team and so
here for example
they played and they could have won or
this team could have won this team could
have won or this team could have won
but these other teams don't seem to have
any matches against them so we can come
across here for the winners and I'll
control click
the teams
that we're excluding and then we'll just
come over here to exclude and you can
exclude a bunch at a time it just adds
it to the filters right here so if I
right click on edit filter you can see
all the teams we've excluded
and then we'll do the same thing on the
toss winners
and we'll control click
and exclude and now we are left with all
the teams that seem to have available
data
between them
and now we want to see
of these toss winners
who won the game so we're going to count
all of the matches
and that will
give us the information we need so I'm
going to grab ID and put it onto text
now what it's doing is giving me all the
IDS so I've got to right click on it and
change it to a measure
and change it to count distinct
and now it will show you how many
matches fit these categories so for this
team if they won when this team wins the
toss
then this team usually wins
which is the same team so I'm going to
widen this out so we can see the names
better
so when the Super Kings win the toss the
Super Kings won the game 42 times let's
right click here and we're going to
change it to
a table calculation again
four percent of total
and what that is saying is that of all
the games
where the Super Kings won the toss they
also won the game 64 percent of the time
now you can read this with the numbers
fairly easily but it'll be a lot easier
if we can also show it in color
so I'm going to change the marks to
square
and I'm going to control drag this onto
color
and now we have
what's called a heat map
and the color is stronger where the
percentage is higher you can see our
range over here
so you can see there's a pretty clear
advantage to the person who wins the
toss
they tend to be the one that wins the
game
when the Daredevils win the toss the
person who wins the game the most is the
Daredevils
let's take this visualization and use it
to analyze a different feature of the
game so I'm going to right click on the
worksheet and I'm going to click
duplicate so now we have the same
visualization twice and I will rename it
to be called
batting
First Advantage
so here instead of toss winner we're
going to bring on batting team
but let's first create a group again
so we're going to don't be confused by
Group by that's not the same thing we'll
go to create and click group
we're gonna put together
control click the team names that have
merged okay
and let's drag
you see how it's not up here right next
to batting team that's because
they put the calculated fields that
we've been making outside of the folders
so if you're looking for a calculated
field you can scroll down to the bottom
and let's drag batting group right over
top of toss winner and it will replace
it right out of there
and we have our gaps again because the
toss winners that we've excluded only
applied to that toss winner so I can
pull off this toss winner filter we
don't need it anymore and then we will
control click
on the ones with the gaps
that we wanted to remove
exclude okay and now we have an analysis
showing
how the batting team does
in our next visualization we're going to
explore who the leading
assessment is
and this could allow you to find out
who's the best if you were in charge of
putting together your team
so we can take all of the batsmen and
put it on row so now we have a list of
every batsman and we can bring batsman
runs onto columns and it will sum up all
of their runs
now what we can do is sort it
from biggest to smallest and we can see
who are our top batsmen
we can bring batsman onto color so I'm
control dragging again
and then they each get their own color
one nice thing that you could do here is
show it filter it by the team
so here we have like team one and team
two but what we would be doing is
filtering It On batting team so we're
going to click show filter
and so if you wanted to see like this is
the best overall but let's see who was
the best to ever work for this team and
then it will sort it from best
down
and you can switch the team if we choose
this one we should choose this one as
well
and now we can see who's the best
another thing that could be really
useful is seeing who's the best by year
so we can come here to date and click
show filter and now we can see this is
the best overall all of these years but
if we just want to see most recently
who's the best that's a very different
story
so filters can be very handy
for looking at a bar chart here
and getting the exact information you
want
we could also maybe just look at the top
five batsmen so what we'll do is we'll
drag batsman onto filters and we'll
create a conditional
filter based on top here
by field so we'll say top 10.
we wanted to look at the top five so
we'll change that to five and we're
looking at the top five batsmen based on
the sum of their runs
so you can choose something else to
filter it by but we want it to be based
on their runs and we hit apply
and there we go we just see the top five
and again if you just want to see the
top five for 2017 here's the top five
for 2017. maybe 2016 and 2017 together
those are your top five
now if we wanted to be able to change
how many we see
um as the developer we could go in and
change it here but if we wanted our end
user to be able to change it then they
can't because when this is published you
can't change your filters that you can't
change the filters that are
the top conditional filters we can
change these filters that we show on the
report called quick filters
but not this guy
you can see we can see now that it's
choosing top five but we we can't select
it
how many so let's get rid of that card
and let's make a parameter that will
allow them to select it so create a
parameter
and we're going to call this top
n
we're going to make it an integer
and it's going to be a range
we'll let them choose
between five and
30.
and they can go up and down by size
we'll click okay so now we have here at
the very bottom parameters
and we can right click on it and click
show parameter control and now we have
this parameter over here called top end
it's set to five and then if I change it
to 10 nothing's happening
and that's because we made the parameter
but we haven't put it anywhere in this
sheet so we're going to put it right
inside of this filter
so you come here and we wanted to use
top how many
you can do it based on a parameter and
we'll do it based on our top end
parameter okay so now when we change it
from five
to ten the parameter updates the filter
so in presentation mode the user can
come in and choose how many they want to
see
now we've only let them go up 30. but
that's to your discretion you could have
this parameter
do whatever you need
so we could say they can go up to a
hundred
and that changes our parameter now we
have all these little marks in between
and here I chose 80. 55
or you could even make it
so that they don't have a step size
they just have a range and they have
just this little slider and it could be
any number in between
but not lower than five and not bigger
than a hundred
let's remove this filter
and we will also
hide this card because we won't give
them the option to choose how many they
want to see in this case we'll just show
them all
so for this next visualization we are
going to look at our top five
and we're going to see how they do over
time so again we're going to start on by
bringing on our batsman
but we only want to see our top five so
let's bring batsman on the filters and
we'll do what I just showed with top
five now since we don't have anything
else on this visualization it's not sure
how to define the top five so we're
going to do it with batsman runs and
we're gonna have the sum of the batsman
runs so top five players over all time
that have
the highest sum of batsman runs highest
sum of runs so here we have them
and we're going to bring on their runs
and we'll sort them biggest the smallest
and next we're going to bring on a time
element so we can see it over time so
I'm going to drag date over here
and now it's doing a line chart for
every
with a DOT for every year
and I'm going to change Year from the
discrete year to The Continuous year
so that it's an axis down here and now
we can see that over time we can bring
batsman on the color so we can see the
different color for each batsman
and here's how they're trending
and then we'll also bring the batsman
runs onto label
and now you can see how many runs they
had
next we're going to take a look at
finding out who our leading Bowlers are
so let's bring all of our Bowlers onto a
visualization
one way to look at this would maybe be
to see which Bowlers have the least runs
associated with them so we can bring the
runs up here and then sort its smallest
to biggest
however they could have very few runs
associated with them because they don't
bowl very often so let's bring on Match
ID and change it to be
a measure that is a count
of match IDs
and we can see that the ones a lot of
these with the least amount of runs also
have the least amount of matches
so it's not a very good indicator
we have here what's called the dismissal
kind
and you can see the reasons that
the batsman was dismissed
and one of them
is hit Wicket so you can see any of the
boulders that hit the wicket
so let's bring dismissal kind on to
filters and we'll just look at those
that hit the wicked
so we have these ones
that have hit the Wicket and let's see
how many times they did that so we'll
actually bring on
down here number of Records
and we'll sort it biggest the smallest
so now we can see that this folder has
hit it twice in our limited set of data
if we include all of the dismissal kinds
except for null so this means that they
were
dismissed for any of these reasons
we can see which Bowlers had the most
dismissals
and let's bring bowler
onto color
great and we'll rename it
to Leading bowler
and we're going to do a similar thing as
we did with top five batsman with
Bowlers so we could start with this
visualization and replace
by clicking right clicking and click
duplicate let's bring it to the end
and now
instead of
top five
batsman we can change it to bowlers
but first let's bring in our dismissal
kind and only choose the ones
so here we can click exclude and we're
going to exclude null
and hit apply so we don't have the nulls
anymore we just have the ones that were
dismissed and we're going to bring in
the bowler on top of the filters and
we're going to have it be based on
the top
count of dismissal kind
top five
okay and we'll put bowler over top of
batsman
we'll take out the sum of batsman runs
and put on our number of Records
and batsman didn't get removed when I
pulled bowler on top of it so I must
have accidentally pulled it in front of
it there we go batsman's gone now here's
a disadvantage to making a copy and then
changing it because it's like what's
happening here but it's because batsman
is still on color and some of batsman is
still on runs so let's take number of
records and put it on to runs
onto the text
and then let's take bowler and put it
onto color
that clears things up quite a bit
so now we can see the bowlers over time
if we take year of date off we can see
which ones are the best overall and
we'll sort it
there we go and then we'll put Year back
on
by dragging date up here
right clicking and changing it to a
continuous there we go so now we have
our top five
and we need to rename this
to top five bowlers
okay
so now we have all these visualizations
and we can start putting them together
into dashboards
so let's make our first dashboard
we're going to have the size
be automatic so it fills the screen here
you have some options with the different
sizes you can have it be a fixed size or
you can Define the width and the height
you could also Define the width and
height based on some of these presets
like a desktop browser or a laptop
browser
you could have it be automatic so it
fills the space
now this will have it fill the space on
any screen so if they're looking at a
much smaller resolution then it'll try
to squish all of your visualizations
into one size so I don't recommend
automatic for
a lot of visualizations because you need
to have extra space
and or if you define this should be here
and this should be over here then it'll
all squish it all together there's also
a range where it's sort of like it's
automatic and it will adjust
based on what screen you're looking at
it however there is a minimum size and
it will never be smaller than that and a
maximum size and it will never be bigger
than that so it won't stretch or shrink
your stuff too far
before adding scroll bars
so here we have automatic
and our first dashboard so we're going
to rename our dashboard
we're going to call it
overall
performance
so the first one we're going to make is
going to be
looking at venue
and run
scored
great so this is our dashboard space so
it says drop sheets here and then these
are our dashboards
and we have other objects down here
that you can also bring on and then over
here we have layout
which after you have brought things on
you can change their layout here
and it will show your item hierarchy
based on how they're nested down here so
on our dashboard
we will first bring in
our matches
and we will bring in our top scorers
and we have
all these different places for matches
our different cities for our top scorers
and so
if we go back to the sheet top run score
we can do that in three ways we can come
down and find the right sheet and click
on it to go to that sheet we can look at
our visualization and click this go to
sheet and it will take us to that sheet
we'll go back
or we can come over here to our sheets
and click go to sheet and we'll take us
to that sheet so let's take our filters
off of the sum of runs so that we're
showing all runs for all cities
you know what instead let's just edit it
so it's filtering out
only those
that never scored more than
say 100.
okay so we have a lot more in here but
it will filter out some of the lowest
ones
we'll go back to our dashboard
and now there's one thing you can do
which is called
an action and so we can click use this
filter
and now when we click on a city over
here it will filter the remaining sheets
on this dashboard to what you've
selected so we can see
how many matches have been done in
different cities and if we want to see
well who are our best players in Mumbai
it will filter down to the top run score
so that's called an action
so let's get rid of that and we'll look
at doing it manually as well so here
under dashboard we have our actions and
you can see there are no actions in here
but then when I come and click use this
filter
then we go to dashboard and actions and
now we have an action called filter1
generated
and what that has done is made an action
based off of the matches in each venue
sheet
and it affects the other sheet
on select
and when you unselect see as it's
clearing the selection will show all
values as doing it based on all fields
okay so if we wanted to make a different
action
which is a URL action on these two
sheets when you select
it'll take you to this website so this
is a Wikipedia beginning page but let's
say we wanted to take you to a specific
Wikipedia page in Wikipedia if you
append on the name of the Wikipedia page
to the end of this URL it will take you
straight to that page
and we're going to assume that there's a
Wikipedia page for all these different
cities
so we have City put in there
and
if we hit okay
okay and now when we click on City
then it will bring up the Wikipedia page
for that city so we come back and we
unselect that and then we come over here
and we pick
a different city
it'll do the same thing and bring up
that Wikipedia page
so right now it's if you click on either
chart it will bring up the Wikipedia
page
we can edit that
by maybe changing it
so that it's only when you pick it in
the top scorer
chart
so when you select something over here
it filters the top scorer chart but when
you select on something in the top
scorer chart it brings up that City
that's just an example and now it's
bringing up that page on a separate
screen so let's
there we go
now we're back
okay
and some more things that we can do
is we'll get rid of this visualization
that it is a legend for how big the
circles are and how what that means
because we have the labels right over
top of the circle so we don't need a
legend for that we'll close that
we have the capability of filtering on
City right now
but when we do filter on city is only
affecting this visualization and not
this visualization
so we can change that
by hovering over apply to worksheets and
then changing it to selected worksheets
and clicking all on the dashboard
and when I click show all worksheets in
the workbook you can see the rest of the
worksheets that are not on the dashboard
are not affected
on the select okay
and now when I filter these
it does it in both places
another thing we can do to make this
look a little nicer is make this a
multiple values drop down
so now it's in a drop down form
we can also
a horizontal
object up here
and put City up inside of there
that's kind of like a header
but we can have some more filters
so if we wanted to be able to filter by
the date
we can put the date on filter there
we'll click use all for now
let's go back to our visualization
we'll click on the visualization we
added it to and hover over filters and
look you can add your date
here it is
let's put it up next to City
and we'll also change it to a multiple
value drop down list
and we'll also have it apply to selected
workbooks all on dashboard
okay
so now you can see
the different years
if we only wanted to see maybe 2017 they
both apply
or they apply to both visualizations
there
and we can have those
and we can add a blank object
over here on the other side of City
so that it doesn't take up quite as much
space
we could put a text object up here too
with the
name maybe the whole workbook or
the sheet
there it is but if we want to edit it
then we can make it bold and we can make
it big
those are some of the things we can do
too
update all of our
different dashboard things
our next dashboard the one that's going
to be about overall performance
we're going to change it to automatic
again
and we're going to bring it
information about performance so we'll
bring in the leading batsman
and I'm leaving bowler
our top five Boulders will go underneath
the bowler information and our top five
batsmen will go underneath the batsman
information you can see that
any filters we had or any
different Legends we had we are showing
up here we don't need these Legends
because we have the names right next to
them so let's get rid of those
when I clicked on
the bowler in that last visualization or
in the last legend it highlighted that
particular bowler so I had to unselect
it before I closed it out okay and then
we had batting teams filter here
which we will not use
but we will use this year filter and now
if I change it it will only affect this
visualization but I want it to affect
all so again this is just a good habit
to have to make sure all of your filters
affect everything on the dashboard that
you want it to affect and that it's very
clear which ones it's affecting
let's give it some space
we can move this whole
piece to along the top here
it doesn't need that much space
and we'll change this
to be a drop down
filter
and it doesn't need all of the space
so we can add
some blank to either side
and have it a little bit more
in the middle here
so now we just want to look at 2017.
we can see our leading batsman and our
leading Bowlers but then you can't see
it over time anymore so let's change our
minds and maybe we only wanted to apply
to worksheets these two worksheets
because we want these worksheets to
still show it over time
so if we click
selected worksheets and we remove our
top five top five
now we can see
that these worksheets update and these
ones do not but one thing to keep in
mind is that these are the top five
overall time
whereas these one two three four five
are the top five for this year
and so these top five are not the same
people you can see as these top five
well this one is
and this one is but it's going to change
and so that's the point
is that
it's important to recognize that these
top five could update
to just the top five for the year we
selected if we still had it applying to
these worksheets
so it's just your call
information over time when filtered to
just one period is
can be not very useful so
our next dashboard
is going to be about advantage
and we're just going to make it so that
we can see
the advantage
of the toss and the advantage of batting
just side by side so let's add a blank
up here
blank down here
and it just gives you a visualization
where you can see the advantage of
winning the toss of the advantage of
batting first one thing that we're
seeing here is that we're getting a
scroll bar because it's too wide to fit
in the selected area
so we could change the visualization
to fit width and then it will make this
shrink to fit inside
the area instead of giving us a scroll
bar
we'll do the same thing here fit width
if we change it to entire view then it
will also change the height to fill this
area
entire View
there we go
so as a recap we have looked at
different ways to look at data so that
you can use it to be help you in your
decisions you can use it to find out who
are your top scorers and which cities
you can use it to figure out who is the
advantage you can use it to help you
figure out if you should choose to go to
the field or to bat you can find your
leading batsman and who should be worth
more to try to get them on your team
same with bowler and you can put them
together into dashboards that are
interactive even out to websites
today we're going to talk about building
dashboards in Tableau based on Cricut
data from the Indian Premier League
please comment below for access to this
data set and somebody from the simply
learn team will get back to you and then
you can follow along if you have any
questions about creating a data source
off of a text data set then go ahead and
comment below or check out tutorial part
one in which we go over that information
so we're going to get started and in
this visualization we're going to look
at batsman information so let me rename
the sheet and I'm going to call it all
innings
score
and so the by the end of this we're
going to have two visualizations two
dashboards one of them focuses on
batsman and one of them focuses on
Bowlers some of the use cases behind
this is if you are trying to figure out
who did the best the batsman and who did
the best of the bowlers for if you were
trying to put together a team so let's
get started we're going to look at
batsman
and here we have listed out all the
batsmen we're going to make this
visualization so that you can look at
just one batsman at a time so I'm going
to right click on batsman and click show
filter and now we have a filter over
here with all of our batsmen and we can
choose just one or all of them let's
just look at one for now and then we're
also going to look at their information
across all of their matches
so we're going to bring on Match ID and
now we have all of the matches for this
batsman now we have quite a few matches
so we're going to allow them to filter
to just one season one year so if I
right click on date and click show
filter it gives me this automatic gear
filter so we'll just filter to maybe
2014 and now we have all those matches
for one year for one batsman and we want
to look at the runs for the batsman so
we'll pull runs out here onto rows and
it now gives us bars for all of those
rows if we were looking at multiple
batsmen so I select all here
it'll section them out by their names
but it's a little bit difficult to tell
where one batsman ends and one begins
sometimes just it's not that visually
easy even though there are lines so we
could make those lines darker or another
thing we could do is take batsman and
pull it onto color and now each batsman
gets their own color and it's a lot
easier to tell the difference let's go
back to just looking at one batsman
and let's sort the matches from smallest
to biggest and as a number of runs so
here we have all the runs for this
batsman per match if we look at multiple
batsman you can see how he did as
opposed to other batsman
there we go
let's
move on to our next visualization it's
going to be about
I'm going to click on the sheet click
rename and click type
type of dismissal
so now we're going to make a chart that
shows you for one batsman for one year
what kinds of dismissals they had so we
want the filters we made on all inning
scores over here to also apply to this
worksheet so let's talk about filters a
little bit when we right click on
filters we can click hover over apply to
worksheets and we have these options we
have all using related data sources all
using this data source or only this
worksheet and that's because we haven't
built a second worksheet yet we have
another worksheet but it doesn't have
the batsman information on it
couple right click on here same thing so
when I bring or any information on this
worksheet we just need to have some
information on this worksheet for it to
start being taken seriously so I drag
dismissal on to color I go back to this
sheet right click and now we should have
another option only this worksheet
selected worksheets all using this data
source are all using related data source
we're going to use the option selected
worksheets now why would we use the
option selected worksheet instead of all
using this data source this is because
we're going to apply these filters to
all of the batsman worksheets but as I
mentioned before we're also going to
make a visualization based on the
bowlers and we're not going to use this
same filter on the bowlers worksheets so
I'm going to click selected worksheets
choose my worksheet and hit OK I'll do
the same thing here on here apply to
worksheet selected worksheet and do the
same thing
okay so because of filters and because
how they can you can have different
filters per worksheet or one filter that
affects two worksheets but not the other
worksheets it's best in my mind to do
all of your filters at the end when
you're actually building the dashboard
so that you can keep track of what the
filter affects and what it doesn't
in this case for our purposes we've done
it already so now we're looking at just
one batsman just one year but my
preference is to do it at the end now we
brought on dismissal kind and put it on
the color and I want to make a pie chart
so I'm going to click on marks and
change it to Pi and right now there's
nothing telling this visualization how
big each slice of the pie should be so
you need to drag something onto angle
let's first make the pie bigger just so
that we can see it better and then let's
also remove the dismissal kind of null
so we have null dismissal kind and
that's when the batter batsman did not
get out however
we're trying to keep track of how many
times they did get out so this isn't
relevant so I right clicked on null over
here and clicked exclude what that did
was made a filter right here on
dismissal kind
and we click edit and you can see it's
excluding null so that's what right
clicking and clicking exclude did so
right now it's doing 1550 it doesn't
know how big to make each angle and we
want it to count the dismissal kind
and that's how it'll determine how big
angle so I'm going to drag this missile
kind on an angle and I get an error why
would I get an error I would get an
error because it's treating it like a
dimension and a dimension is by
definition not something you use to
measure things with and so you can't say
this angle should be this big based on a
dimension
so we're going to change it to a measure
which is when we're going to count
the dimensions so
we're going to do a count of dismissal
kind so if they got out because they
were bowled out then we'll count how
many times that happened and that will
determine the red angle or the orange
angle and if it was caught that will
determine
the red angle so count great so now we
can see
five and six so
four
this batsman for this year
he was out 11 times five times because
it was caught five times because it was
bold
let's control and drag this missile kind
on the label so now we can quickly see
the five and the six and we're going to
control drag dismissal kind onto label
and we can see which kind
of dismissal it was that keeps us from
having to need this Legend
so we can click hide card and we don't
need that anymore
now we're going to make another pie
chart based on runs so since I'm making
a second pie chart I'm going to
duplicate this
there are some pros and cons to
duplicating it one of the pros is when
we come up here to filters
and we come to selected sheets we can
see that the filters that applied to
type of dismissal are automatically
applied here onto type of dismissal two
and so that's great news because we do
want it to be filtered to just one
batsman in just one year however we
don't want it to filter out dismissal
kind of null anymore because now we're
looking at runs and runs
need to have the times when they didn't
get out so we're gonna pull this missile
kind off
and if you weren't paying very close
attention or you dot copied it then you
might be confused as to why things were
getting filtered out but it was because
it copied your filters as well so that's
one of the disadvantages of copying
let's rename it runs distribution
and I'm gonna pull off all of this
information here so that we're starting
from scratch so here we have basically
blank pie chart
and we're going to
look at batsman runs
so there are a couple different kinds of
runs that you can get so I want batsman
runs to determine color but when I drag
batsman runs onto color it's doing a sum
of batsman runs
and it's just trying to make it darker
or lighter depending on how many runs
there were but that's not what I want I
want to use it as a dimension and now we
can see we have zero through six and
that means that a batsman either has
zero runs or one two four or six runs
now there is three runs as well however
because we're only selecting one year
and one batsman this particular batsman
for this particular year only had
either zero runs one run two four or six
so when we change it to a dimension it's
now instead of summing up all the runs
it is now just showing you their options
but it's still doing it like a scale
from light to dark I want six distinct
colors one for each so I'm going to
change it from a continuous
type of field to a discrete type of
field
and now I have zero one two four and six
now I want to exclude zero runs because
I'm not trying to keep track of how many
times they didn't get a run I'm trying
to keep track of what how many times
they got different kinds of runs so
again let's exclude it and now we have
our four different kinds and just to
show this I right clicked on year I
click show filter
and if I show all the years you can see
our fifth kind
of run where they got three runs on one
ball
shows up so it does exist it just didn't
happen for this particular batter or
batsman during that year now we want the
angle to be determined by
batsman runs
however we don't want to sum up the
batsman runs we don't want to take every
time that he got a six and do six plus
six plus six plus six what we want to do
is count how many times he got a six so
we're going to change it from a sum
to account
and you can see he got
a six 24 times
and so before let's go back
it was taking 24 and timesing it by 6
which is 144.
and summing up each of those times but
instead we want to count each of those
times and see how many times he got a
six and how many times he got a four not
how many points were scored
when um by getting a six so
that's a little bit of a confusing thing
to think about another thing you could
do is instead of doing a count of
batsman runs
let's pull that off you could use this
number of Records field and that will
show us how many
meaning the number of records how many
records did we have from this batsman in
this year
that showed
that he batted a six so drag number of
Records onto angle and you see we get
the same thing that we had before so
those are two ways of doing it either
change the
batsman runs to account or grab a number
of Records number of Records is a little
bit simpler so let's also bring number
of Records onto the label and we can see
quickly that mostly he got ones and got
more fours than he got twos actually
which might is might be interesting too
people who are trying to see how well
this batsman does
our next visualization has to do with
the batsman strike rate
so we'll make our new sheet
season
strike rate
and we'll need to make a calculated
field
to be able to determine the strike rate
for a batsman so we'll come here to this
arrow click on it and click create
calculated field
we'll call it strike rate and we're
going to find out how many runs that a
batsman gets basically for every 100
Balls bold so we're going to
get the total of the runs by doing a sum
of batsman runs
we're going to divide it by the number
of balls bold we know that this data set
is one row per ball bold
it's the ball by ball data so we're just
going to divide it by how many the
number of rows number of Records
and we're going to put all of that
in parentheses and one thing I need to
do is instead of just number of Records
I needed to be the sum of number of
Records so that it adds them all up
before it divides it
okay so some of the runs divided by the
sum of the Bold balls and we will
multiply that by 100 and that is our
strike grade okay so now that we have
our strike rate we can start building
our visualization
we would like to have
both of these filters so I'm going to
quickly apply it
so first build the visualization and
then apply it we're going to
come here and bring date onto columns
and it's giving us one per year we're
gonna change our marks card
no let's leave our marks card the way it
is and then we are going to bring on our
bowler
and we're going to bring on our strike
rate
okay
so now that we have kind of the
beginnings of our visualizations let's
go here and we can now apply it to our
new worksheet apply the existing filters
one of the reasons it's so important to
apply the existing filters
to our worksheet
there we go now we can see quickly see
his strike rate for 2014. I'm going to
control drag strike weight onto label
and we have it there as well
okay one of the reasons it's so
important to use the same filter that is
applied to all of the selected
worksheets
instead of just bringing batsman back on
and making our new filter each time is
we want on the dashboard to just have
one filter that applies to all of them
so you can see here when I change this
to 2015
and remove 2014 and then we go to season
strike great we can see this one's also
2015 now
and we'll go back to 2014
season strike rate and this one is also
2014. so we want whenever a filter is
changed for it to affect all of the
visualizations associated with our
dashboard and so all of our
visualizations that are about batsman
and their information we want to be able
to use the same filters
so I'm going to click show filter
quickly
and we're going to see what happens to
this dot when they add more years
so this is going to allow them to see
the strike rate per 100 Balls over time
if they select more periods
our next visualization is going to be
called
team versus
player
and we're going to see how many runs a
Batson has scored against particular
teams
so we're going to bring on bowling team
because that's the team the batsman is
against we're going to bring on
batsman
and there
that's been run
so now you can see how many runs each
batsman scored against all these
different teams
and again
we're going to apply our filters
there we go
let's also bring batsman onto color
again
just for when we're looking at multiple
batsmen at once in our filters and we're
going to bring the batsman runs onto
label
there we go so now we can have it in
both places instead of just pulling it
off and putting it on the new one great
team versus player
and our last visualization for the
batsman dashboard
is going to be called
balls per boundary
so we're going to see how many balls
bold it takes for a batsman to get a
boundary but we have balls for per
boundary calculated here
and also a boundaries count calculated
here however we're going to show you how
to make our own versions of these
calculations so I'm going to create a
calculated field I'm going to call it
boundaries count
and it won't let me save it as
boundaries count because I can't have it
saved as the same name at least in
Tableau desktop that's true I'm not it
looks like tablet public isn't getting
mad at me for that so but I'm going to
change the name to
boundaries count calculated
so we can tell the difference between
the one that existed and the one that we
calculated and we are going to
do an if statement so if the batsman
runs
the individual batsmans runs not the sum
over whatever we select if bassman's run
is greater than or equal to four
then one else
zero
so
it's giving me an error because I always
need to have an end
whenever I do an if statement
and this shows that whenever a boundary
happens so if they scored four or six on
one ball
then we'll count it one otherwise zero
and if I sum this up then we'll be able
to count how many boundaries they had so
apply
okay and for example if I brought on a
batsman all the batsman
and I brought on boundaries count
calculated
this should be
counting up how many boundaries they had
overall time
so that's the numbers we're getting here
okay let's back it out now we're going
to make our new calculated field called
balls per boundary
calculated
just so that it's clear which one is
which and we're going to count
all the balls so this is for every ball
bolt so we're counting the balls we
could also use the number of Records
here similar to what we talked about
earlier and we're going to divide it by
the sum
of
the boundaries count calculated
so this will show us how many balls it
takes to get a boundary apply okay
great now we can start building our
visualization
and we are going to bring on
batsman onto columns
and we're going to bring balls per
boundary calculated onto rows and now
it's showing us
how many balls it takes
for the boundaries let's also bring
that's been onto color
I've got to hold Ctrl when I do that
there we go
so we have batsman here and batsman here
and we're gonna do the same thing hold
Ctrl drag this down to label
now we can see the exact number
and for the final time we're going to
apply our filters
now I could have waited and applied my
filters at the very end once I had all
these built again I do recommend
applying your filters at the end
now we're going to put together the
first of our two dashboards so I'm going
to click on dashboard here I'm going to
change it to automatic size which will
fill my screen I'm going to change it
back to fixed size so now we have our
width and our height based on what
automatic size was let's just round it
out a little bit so instead of 1678 I'm
going to change it to be
just an even 1600 and same even 900. so
now we have our fixed size here
there's also you can change it to a
laptop browser or a full screen so if we
click full screen that there's that size
generic desktop
I'm gonna go back to my size the size
that works for you is going to be based
on the size that works the best for all
of your users so that will take some
research on your side and before I get
started I'm going to do some formatting
of my dashboard so I'm going to click
format here and I'm going to change the
default shading for the dashboard
to
this particular
shade
you can use this color selector or all
these different kinds of basic colors
and so it just gives it a different
color than just the basic white so
that's a quick way to change the whole
dashboard color and I'm also going to
bring on
some text for the title of the dashboard
let's name our dashboard
we're going to call it batsman
performance
so
actually spell it out there okay and
then down here it says show dashboard
title so I'm going to select that and we
have batsman performance there at the
top
if you don't want the title here to
match what's here you have a couple
options so you can click edit title and
put in whatever you want
you can also come we'll click floating
here and we're going to just drag a text
on here and
that allows you to be able to make your
own title like that as well or just
whatever text you need to put on your
dashboard so we'll just remove that from
our dashboard and we're going to bring
on our visualizations but we're going to
bring them on as floating visualizations
so I've selected floating here versus
tiled floating allows you to bring
something on and drop it and wherever it
lands is where it lands and you can move
it around and it's not going to try to
automatically fill this area
if I change it to tile
and I bring this on it'll fill the area
or I'll put it to the left or the right
and it will fill those sides so back to
floating floating has some benefits
where you can just drop things and they
will land there however if you make it
floating then you have to adjust the
size of each individual thing instead of
just say if we brought it on
undo that I'm as tiled and we brought on
this and we brought on this if I wanted
to adjust the size of these things I can
just drag this little line in between
and it just tiles them and they fill the
space you give them
versus with floating when I bring on
this
and I bring on this
then I have to if I want to adjust the
sizes I can make this one smaller and
then I need to make this one bigger
independently of that
so there are some pros and cons of doing
it either way
but we are going to do it the floating
way
and we are going to bring on team versus
player first
you just put it here
then we're going to bring on
underneath that
type of dismissal
so basically all of our dashboards one
at a time
here's where our balls for boundary goes
my runs distribution goes over here
and it brings in whatever
filters you showed
at the time and now the legends that are
showing up on that visualization so if I
go back to Run's distribution you can
see we had gear and that Legend on there
and it brought them in as well but let's
also bring on
season strike rate
which also had here and all ending score
okay so this is the one that had all
ending score if you recall was the first
one we made that originally had R2
filters so we're going to change our
filters from multiple value list to
multiple value drop down and that causes
it to take up way less space
it still has an incredible height so
we're gonna be able to lay out and we're
going to change the height
too
something more reasonable
100 just brings it onto the screen so
that I can drag it like that there we go
and then
year of date
we're going to edit this one
let's see
to be multiple value drop down as well
and again a more reasonable height for a
multiple value drop down Okay so we've
got started
we have this Legend here for color for
batsman which we're going to remove
because it has the name on it generally
and we're going to figure out how wide
we want these to be so we need all three
of them to fit in our
width
1600 so that would be a width around 500
each so let's go to layout here and
we're going to change the width from 533
to 500.
on each of these visualizations
and that gives us some extra
space to go in between them all
it's a little bit more reasonable the
space in between
there we go
run distribution
so
once I've kind of figured out my spacing
to go in between them I can line up
these bottom ones by matching
the Y
or x x value so this x is 25
and this one I want it to line up with
it up and down so I'll change my X to 25
and it shifts it over
this one is 555. so I'm going to change
this one
and this one
I'm just going to copy and paste this
one
into this one
now we kind of have the X figured out
and I want them all to line up along the
Y as well so I'm going to take this
170.
and I'm going to apply the 170
to all three of these so that they line
up perfectly
this is another benefit of having it be
a floating object because on a tile
object you can't determine their
position exactly otherwise
it would mess up all the tiles around it
but you also don't need to put them
quite as precisely in order because when
you do tiled it kind of lines them up
along lines as they are
great so this is a lot more
straightforward
let's get these
I'll get this guy about where I want it
and then I'll line this one up with it
up and down
there we go
we can also
come here and edit the title and just
make the font a little bit bigger
on both of these
and now let's make the worksheets here
individually a little bit closer to the
color that we
picked for our background so I'm going
to click right click right on top of the
chart and click format then I'm going to
go to the shading section and on the
worksheet I'm going to choose more
colors you see the color that we
selected before for the background is in
this little palette of recently used
colors and I want one slightly different
than that so I'm just going to enter in
the one that I want
and I'll copy that so I could use it on
the others
however if I did want the same color as
I had there I could just select it right
at the recently used colors okay
and there we go we'll come here right
click on chart click format shading and
I'm gonna paste in
that color
and you see when I click from here to
here it kept me right on that same sheet
however you see that this went to white
instead of the darker color I had before
and so
I don't even have to click format again
I can just come here
and paste in
my color
so I have a color that matches more
closely to my background color but it's
still different enough that I still have
the outline kind of the shape of having
like cards on this dashboard
we'll go full screen here we now have
our dashboard that allows us to see
all of the batsman performance
information for whatever batsman we
choose and whatever year we choose so
when we change the year
all the charts update
we want to
change the Batson
to
one of these Chris's
there we go some of them aren't in the
year 2014 which is the problem we were
having there we go so now we see all the
same information but for Chris instead
so now that we've made our batsman
dashboard we're going to move on to
making our bowler dashboard
our first visualization for the bowler
is going to be called
Fuller performance
against team it's very similar to the
one that we made for batsman only it's
showing how the bowler has performed
against batting teams
and the wickets that they got against
those batting teams so we're going to
bring on
the batting team
so we can see all the batting teams
against them
we're going to bring on bowler
so that it separates It Out by bowler
one more try we'll also put bowler onto
color
and we're going to bring on
player dismissed
no sorry
we're going to bring on dismissal kind
we've got on dismissal kind but I want
to change it to be a measure and a count
of the dismissal kinds
let's put it here
so now we have a bar chart
for the dismissal kind you can see that
it's going 0 to 30 for each of these
and that's because we have some that go
all the way up to 30 against a team
and if we wanted we could edit the axis
and change it to be independent axis
ranges for each row or column
so now we can see that it is zero to two
for this guy
but 0 to 30 for this guy
and that can be nice
when
you want to be able to look at them
independently however when we're looking
at them side by side and you're trying
to compare we would think that maybe
this person did just as good
as somebody like
this person
so we're not going to do that
because it could be misleading
also in the end I'm going to have
filters that we're looking at one bowler
at a time and one year at a time so
we won't need
to see them all at once okay
we have bowler on color let's also
control drag the count of dismissal kind
on the label so now it's labeled
some of them are going to have a lot
fewer against teams maybe they didn't
play as many seasons and that they might
have a lot more that's why we're going
to have the filter for a per season
number
but we're not going to do that right
away
okay
next workbook
and worksheet
and we're going to call it
Fuller versus player
so when we're looking at this at one
bowler at a time we can see how the
bowler has done versus particular
players
so we're going to bring on the batsman
here
and then we're going to bring on
dismissal kind here and again we're
going to change it to account measure
and we can count all the dismissals
against particular players when we
filter it down to one bowler we can see
how they did versus certain players and
then in just one year
let's sort
biggest to smallest
we're going to
bring batsman
on to color
and
that way when we switch from
bowler to bowler we could kind of see
which batsman fall in certain areas it
also just makes it
quick to follow it along to the edge and
we could put counter dismissal on the
label here
so that it's easy to quickly see however
when we filter it down to just one
bowler and one year then there's going
to be a lot fewer dismissals per batsman
so
it'll be pretty easy to see so let's not
do that let's go on to our next
worksheet
and this one is going to be called
bowling average
so we need to create a bowling average
calculation
it's going to be runs conceited per
wickets taken so we have to come up with
our runs conceited which is all of the
batsman runs we'll sum those up and
divide it by
the number of wickets which is the count
of dismissal kind
and now we have our bowling average
there is a bowling average that already
existed so again we're going to call it
bowling average calculated
so that we know which one's ours okay
apply done and we're going to bring on
the bowler
and Boulder onto color
and let's bring on our bowling average
calculated
I'm gonna sort it biggest to smallest
it might be better to sort it smallest
to biggest
but some of these players might not have
played
or bold
so that's why we'll have Mills
so
biggest to smallest it is
and let's also bring the bowling average
that we made
onto
the label
great
our next sheet we will also need to make
a calculated field for this one
and let me hurry and name it and then
I'm going to go back to bowling average
because I had
one more thing to do there
economy rate
is our next sheet okay so for bowling
average we have a situation where maybe
somebody doesn't know what the bowling
average means so
you can right click on your chart in the
outside area outside of the graph area
and click on caption
and the caption will pop up and it's
automatically making a caption which is
bowling average calculated for each
bowler it's just describing what's
happening and as those color shows
details about the bowler which it does
and the marks are labeled by the bowling
average calculated
so when I double click on the caption I
can change it to be whatever I want
which I'm going to put
runs conceited
per wicket
taken
and now we have a caption that kind of
is describing what this visualization
means
so on economy rate the economy is
defined as the number of runs conceded
for each over bold so instead of the
runs conceded per Wicket taken it's for
each over so we're going to create our
calculated field we're going to call it
economy
calculated
again we have to give the sum of our
runs
there's our runs we're going to divide
it by
the count of the balls so this will tell
us how many
balls were thrown and but we don't want
how many balls were thrown we want how
many overs there were
so just to make this a little more clear
I'm going to put parentheses around this
and we're going to take there are six
balls thrown in and over so we're going
to take the number of balls and divide
it by six
to get the number of overs so we'll take
batsman runs and then this is per over
okay
for this visualization it's going to be
pretty similar
to the last one
or we're going to bring on economy
and we're going to put economy onto I'm
going to hold Ctrl and put it onto label
sum of economy oh it's not even using my
calculated field so
economy calculated
there we go now it's much more
reasonable we'll drag economy calculated
onto label and since this dashboard is
going to be meant to be viewed one
bowler at a time we're going to not
split it out by bowler in this situation
but you could and if you do split it out
by bowler that means they could select
more than one bowler at a time and see
their economy side by side
also here we can see that it says
economy calculated for our label have we
hit edit axis we can change the title
so we're just going to call economy
probably need to do the same thing for
bowling average there we go edit axis
bowling average okay it got mad because
I didn't close it and then there we have
it again I'm going to right click in
some empty space and click caption and
then we have our caption here
edit caption and we're going to put
average
runs conceded
okay
there we go we have our caption we have
our chart
and we have one more visualization to
make for our dashboard
remember if you have any questions or
comments please put them below and
somebody from the simply learn team will
help us answer those questions or if you
have an answer to somebody else's
question feel free to chime in we'll get
a good discussion going
the last one is called a dismissal
and we're going to look at kind of like
we did before type of dismissal but this
was the batter and how they got
dismissed whereas this is the bowler and
how they took the wicked so
we are going to also make a pie chart
which means dismissal kind goes on to
color and we change the marks to Pi so
we have a pie that shows a color for
each of the dismissal kinds again let's
remove null so again I came over here
right clicked and clicked exclude but
you can do it right on the visualization
dismissal kind and you say oh it's blank
instead of bold or cotton bold
and click exclude there so there it
makes our filter next we need to
determine the angle size we're going to
bring on number of Records
and the more records that fall under
that dismissal kind that means the more
often that kind happened
and let's bring number of rows number of
Records onto label as well
and also
we're going to entire View
so that it's nice and big and easy to
read and we're going to
add a caption
and
we're just going to put
dismissal types
but we'll see how that comes up on the
visualization so now that we have made
all of our
visualizations for our dashboard let's
add our filters so just on this last one
I'm going to bring bowler onto filter
and we're going to click use what's
actually select a bowler
you can use this box to search
there we go and it's popped up you see
how I didn't even have to start
searching it at the beginning of the
name
it's just smart enough so we have our
bowler
let's bring on date
we're gonna choose years
and let's choose 2016.
and we have our year and now let's apply
it
to all the worksheets that it applies to
so dismissal economy rate bullying
average bullying versus player and
bowler performance against team
for a year
okay and you can see how much quicker
that is to apply
instead of doing it every time you make
a new dashboard
so much quicker saves you some time can
be confusing so make sure you do it
because if you forget to do it and then
you change a filter on a dashboard and
it only changes one of the
visualizations on that dashboard then it
can be really confusing and
like on the batsman performance if we
had forgotten to add these to all the
visualizations and we left it off of
this visualization then
people could be confused as to why
that's not changing or off of this
visualization if it's not changing it's
hard to know if it's not changing
because it didn't change from year to
year maybe his types of dismissal were
the same from year to year
or
it's just hard to tell the difference
and see if it's not affecting it so
always be sure to double check
that your filters are applied to
everything you need them to be applied
to
let's make a dashboard
okay
we're going to make it
but we made it before
1600 by 900. and you can see all of our
sheets are showing up but let me show
you a quick trick here this dashboard
uses all of the batsman sheets and we
don't use any of the batsman sheets
again inside of the second dashboard so
if I right click on the batsman
performance and I click hide all sheets
it doesn't hide all sheets it just hides
all sheets associated with that
dashboard and now you no longer see
those sheets and then I come to
dashboard two it's only showing me the
sheets that are not hidden
for that dashboard
let's get started by first changing our
dashboard color so I came to dashboard
and I hit format
and I'm going to change the color to
this blue color
and there's our background
and then I'm going to click show
dashboard title which is dashboard 2
right now so let's Rectify that right
now and we're going to call it
color performance
and here we have bowler performance
let's do floating which is already
selected
and we're going to bring on Boulder
performance against team
and we're going to go side by side with
bowler versus player
and it's brought on
both of these have brought on
legends that are actually not helpful
because we have labels that tell us
these things so we're going to get rid
of these Legends
sometimes I wait till I brought I have
brought on all of my dashboards before I
remove Legends or change filters so all
of our all of my worksheets sometimes I
wait till I've brought on all my
worksheets I'm gonna bring on bowling
average
and economy rate
and dismissal
here's an actually useful Legend so
we'll keep that around
remove this Legend
because right there just tells you right
next to it
and now let's start adjusting our charts
so I'm going to make these two side by
side up here so they need to split the
space
so let's try a width of
which gives you a little bit of space
side to side
but still uses the space a little bit
better
you can see that this visualization is
too tall to fit inside of the area we've
given it so it has a scroll bar here on
the side
if you change
how this fills in its space so right now
it's standard you can have fit width
which it's already fitting the width of
the area that is provided if you do fit
height it's going to force everything to
fit inside of that area so there's no
scroll bar and it does not look good for
this visualization
and an entire view it's the same thing
as trying to make everything fit inside
that area so we're gonna go back to
standard another one that's good for
things but you do want the scroll bar up
and down is fit width so either of those
look good
um these two are going to share a space
underneath this one
and so I'm going to make them
both
let's say
how does that look oh that's good
let's make this one the same size as
this above it
bring it over
okay
you notice one thing
that's happening here is
we cannot see at this point the filters
there are no filters popping in here
even though we added filters now why
would that be that's because we have no
filters being shown on our visualization
none of our worksheets showed the
filters they just existed here so if we
come and we click on one of our
visualizations click the drop down arrow
and we go to filters we can see all the
filters we can select from
we're going to bring on bowler
let's make it
the drop down
and again it's just made it a really
unreasonable height because I was trying
to fit all of those bowlers
but 20 is too small
there we go
and we'll go here and also bring on
year of date
what's the height on this one 55 55 is a
good height
now it's time to clean it up a bit so we
have all of our pieces
let's first make sure when I change this
that everything changes so when I
unselect 2016 they should all go to null
and I click Fit 2015 they all update
that's what we want to see
okay so we have all the pieces we just
need to get them lined up looking nice
and
just getting things a little bit more
clean
like here
we want to show our caption
that we added
and here
so this kind of
is something that you can use on your
dashboard to describe things that are
happening or different pieces of it it's
just an easy way
to add a caption and then let's line
them up up and down I think that we
could probably make both of these a
little taller
what do we think about 350
maybe even 400
I will bring
these ones down
that's really nice for this
visualization to have more space
just a little bit more space whatever
you can give it honestly
is really helpful
sometimes with these visualizations that
are up and down I like to give them the
whole side to themselves so maybe we
would move this over and make it smaller
and these all three would fit right here
and then I'd give this one all of this
up and down space I'll undo that
we can move this Legend over a little
bit more
here we go
and then let's start lining things up I
like where this one is positioned
on the y-axis so I'm going to copy that
and bring it over here
they were pretty close there we go
and then
I'm going to
do the same thing with the y-axis for
these ones
just to make sure they're perfectly
lined up
these it looks like I could make a
little bit wider
if you would like one thing that's
happening here is it looks a little bit
like this one has more up and down space
than this one does
um and that's because it's missing this
label and it also isn't colored the same
as these other ones as it represents the
bowler well we can fix that because if
you remember we did not put bowler onto
the columns and we put it on there
there's our label
we also didn't put it onto color and
there we go so that gives us a little
bit more consistency
between these two visualizations however
they're still labeled economy rate and
bowling average with their captions at
the bottom there
okay
and since these are the same width I
would like to line them up on the x-axis
so
I'm going to take this
there and that lines those up I want to
make sure that these are lined up
and down pretty close not quite there
there we go and also year of date
is not necessarily what I want
the update part is
just
not useful for what we need so I'm going
to change it to year I'm also going to
center it
will come here for bowler
and send her that one as well
Center and also let's make it a little
bigger see how it did not make it bigger
that is because the formatting
in here
such as changing the font or Bolding it
requires you to have whatever text you
want selected
so now it's bigger
there we go
I like the white on the blue so I won't
change these individual dashboards
or individual worksheets to be a
different color
let's take a look
here we have our second dashboard
if we come here and we click hide all
sheets now you can only see the two
dashboards
in these tabs at the bottom
and you can see that we can have
different years for the two different
dashboards you could tie the Year
together
oh we have year of date on this one too
let's change that
so
that's not
what I meant to click there we go edit
title
we're gonna make it centered I'm gonna
make it bigger
don't press enter when you're not done
now we're going to erase update so
that's just year
do the same thing over here
this just adds a little bit of
consistency
they are two separate dashboards
but if people are going to look at them
side by side maybe or one right after
the other it is nice to have some
consistency
there we go
so there you have it we have made two
dashboards
one of them about batsman performance
one of them about baller performance
during this time we learned about
formatting our dashboards we learned
about floating versus tiled and about
positioning Legends and filters
um some of the options we have for
changing filters
we learned about different ways to make
different visualizations we made pie
charts and bar charts
and we also learned about applying
filters to just the worksheets that you
want for those dashboards
finally we learned about adding captions
so at first we'll understand what
exactly a set function is then we'll
understand the sort function next we
have the join and Union and by the way
we use it after that we have the
Highlight function in W then we have the
device designer and finally the forecast
now these are the functions in Tableau
that we will be discussing today don't
worry I'll explain each one of them with
practical examples so that you have a
better learning experience now let's
dive into the first one which is the set
so what exactly is a set
so set and W are basically a set of
elements basically if you have some
variety of columns and rows then you
customize some selected data for example
if you have a set of cars sales data and
inside that you have some details about
the horsepower the price values the
resale values etc etc and you wanted to
make a set of the cars with the highest
horsepower then you can do that just by
adding some conditions onto your data so
that's what the set functions in table
you basically do
so we have an example on our screen
right now so this is how the set
function will be implemented in W and
you'll be getting some similar kind of
output now we'll go back to Tableau and
try to do it practically now we are back
on W and in Tableau let's try to make a
set
and for that let's create a new sheet
yeah now let's rename this sheet
as a set function
okay
now let's try to drag the
engine size onto columns
now we have the engine size on our
columns now the next let's choose the
horsepower
so we have our horsepower on the rows
now you can see that we have a resultant
dot which is the total number of engine
size values and total number of
horsepower including of all the cars now
let's try to drag the manufacturer into
the details part
so that we have the um you know kind of
which manufacturer has the horsepower
values and the engine size etc etc
so we have the Ford and the overall
according to the data set we have the
overall engine size is 36.60 now it's
not you know this is not the kind of
data you want to look at so now let's
remove the manufacturer from here and
let's select the model
yeah now we have a little more detailed
one just hover onto yeah you can see
this so we have the model Corvette and
the engine size is 5.7 liters and the
horsepower is 345.
now let's try to drag the manufacturer
again onto the details so that we can
have also the name of manufacturer
so we have the manufacturer Chevrolet
model Corvette engine size and
horsepower now we have the data what we
needed now let's try to create a set
Now to create a set you might want to
have to select the
let's undo that
yeah
Now to create a set you might want to
select the values on here
so these are the selected parts we have
with the highest horsepower
now let's right click
and then we have an option called create
set in the last option
now let's just try to rename the set
name now we have it as set one now let's
try to name it as
horsepower
set
and before you know we select OK if you
want to eliminate some names or cars you
can do that as well for example if you
want to eliminate Cadillac develop you
can just select and remove it you can
also do it in this way
I'm a Cadillac Escalade you can just
exclude it and it's it'll be gone
yeah something like that
and if you want this set to be added
onto the filters tab or filter shelf you
can just select it over here and it will
be automatically done
for now I think we don't need it on to
the filter shelf so we'll just select
okay
and there you go we have the horsepower
set over here
now to watch the um set what we created
over here in a pictorial way or a
graphical way you can just drag that and
you can just add it over the chart pane
people
now if you wanted to look at the data
which you have in your set then you can
just drag that set onto the color option
and you'll be having a different color
on your data which is present in your
set
and I can just right click on it and you
can
make some changes to it if you wanted to
make or if you want to keep this you can
just click on the option keep only and
if you wanted to exclude it you can just
select exclude and it'll be gone
so this is how you use sets in W now
let's move on to the next function which
happens to be the sort function
so what exactly is sort
so when you open w you can see some
options on Tableau which are the uh some
bar kind of things on the toolbar so
these are basically sort options so sort
and Tableau is a function which is
readily available for the user to sort
the resultant data in the form of
ascending or descending order so we have
a sample picture which shows the sort
functions used in real time now let's
get back to the Tableau and say it for
real
so now we have the highest pricing chart
over here
yeah you can see yeah let's select this
one
so we have multiple car manufacturers
and the car models available in that
particular section now these are kind of
irregularly sorted now one press of this
button which happens to be sorted
descending by sum of horsepower within
model
you see
within mod all the models are sorted
according to the horsepower so the first
one in Buick the Regal model which has
the highest horsepower 240 and the next
highest is two note five second two not
five and then 175 so this is how the
models have been sorted now you can make
this look a bit more colorful just by
dragging the model onto color and you
can see the different colors
so that's how it is
now followed by sort we'll move on to
the next one
which happens to be the join and Union
now the join and Union are completely
similar to the join and Union functions
which you basically use in the SQL and
database
so you can see on the left part we have
the four different types of joints which
are the inner left right and full outer
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so join and Union in Tableau are used to
combine data from different sources and
they're completely similar to the ones
and SQL and database operations
imagine that you have various kinds of
data sources and you need to work on
those various types of data sources in
Tableau for example consider that you
have some shopping data some store data
so you have the customer data separately
and the product data separately
and let's assume that in both the tables
we have one common column that is the
order ID
so the customer will be requesting for a
product and will be creating an order ID
and in the product table you'll be
having the product data along with the
requested product with its order ID when
you have such kind of common column then
you can basically join the two data sets
and no matter what if you have the
orders data in notepad and the product
data in Excel format you can do it you
can join them it doesn't matter if you
have the data
Source in different formats
so that's why we have join and Union in
tableview
so let's get back to W and try to do it
manually
so now I have kind of uh Excel
now let's select the store data
repeat and you have the store data and
now let's try to add the new data set
now for that you just need to select the
add option
now we have the other options now we
have already included Microsoft Excel
now let's try to include the CSV file
the text file so I've already created
one
so this happens to be the returns data
now there you go you have both the data
sets over here which is the Microsoft
Excel and the Microsoft not Microsoft
it's text file so you can see the new
Union option over here you can use new
Union option and try to combine both of
them based on the order ID which is
present in both the tables
so this is how the join and Union
basically work in Tableau now let's try
to continue with the next one
the next one is highlight
the Highlight function is pretty simple
you just have to you know select the
option which you want to showcase it's
as simple as the name is
so the Highlight in W is a function
readily available to help the user to
highlight a specific data out of the
complete file
so basically you can see my screen and
on the screen we have the data set and
we have a resultant bar chart and on
that we have the highest pricing of a
particular car manufacturer and when you
hover on to that particular bar and
select it then you can see that that
particular bar has been highlighted
now this data is also the same one and
on the right side part I've just
selected the BMW car manufacturer and
you can see the cars highlighted are
based on that particular car maker now
we are back on Tableau and now we have
the same data over here now let's just
kind of sort it again
and you see here and now if I select uh
the
Mercedes-Benz you can see that
particular car has been highlighted over
here
so that's how we use highlight function
and you can see if you want to disable
highlighting you can do it by just
clicking this button disable workbook
highlighting
so now with this let's move ahead into
the next kind of function
which happens to be the device designer
so device designer is really simple
there is no rocket science in that it's
basically the kind of device you're
working with so if you have the Tableau
installed in your tablet then you can
just select the tablet option so that
your dashboard is clearly visible
according to the screen size of your
table or tablet and if you're using a
desktop then you can select the desktop
option and you can directly do it now
let's get back to Tableau and check the
device designer
so basically the device designer is used
to check the layout of the dashboard you
have you can select the fitward fit
height and entire View
so you also have the options for
making your dashboard look in the phone
mode
and you can either select the default
where your device automatically selects
the kind of view it wants to show
so that's how the device designer is
used in real time
now let's get back to the next one which
is the forecast so forecast is one
interesting function used in real time
so let's imagine that you wanted to have
an information based on the future sales
on the
product based on the current data
available now you can do that by using
the forecast function in your tablet
so as you can see on my screen I have
some information available based on the
sample data now we have the sales charts
on 2014 15 16 17 and if you wanted to
predict the data of sales in the next
upcoming year which is 2018.
I'm saying 2018 as the future year here
because the data set what we have only
has information until 2017 so that's the
reason I'm saying the future year 2018
Doom no worry a lot about it we can
actually change it in the data set if
you wanted to now let's see this
practically happening in tableau
now we are back on Tableau and we are
about to create the forecast thing so we
have the measures and dimensions on the
left part now let's try to drag the
sales
now we are dragging sales onto rows and
we're going to drag the order date onto
the columns
so we have the graph over here now if
you kind of
press that little plus button and then
you can see the sales happening
according to 14 15 16 and 17th year now
let's try to select the analytics to
create the forecast thing now you just
have to uh you can see the forecast
button over here right you can just have
to double click on that and you can see
that the Tableau is predicting the sales
over here and this is the best uh case
and this is the worst case of sales and
this is kind of the average
so this is how the forecast Works in
real time
so we will get started by understanding
the proper definition of the parameter
in w
so what exactly are parameters in
tableau
so parameter will allow you to provide a
value to pass into tablet parameters
allow you to produce scenarios or
options that are not available in your
data or create these values to put it
into your visualization after creation
end users can control the input to see
the results of the parameters effect
so this is a little complex to
understand so let me just break it down
to a simpler version so parameters are
completely similar to filters so when
you apply a filter just imagine that you
wanted to find the sales of top 10
subcategory items so which are easy
phones is it Furniture is it something
else so which are the top 10 items which
are finding me the most profitable sales
so you'll apply that filter to that
particular sheet so what if you wanted
to apply the same filter to 10 sheets
Yeah by brute force method you can do
that and you can apply that to the 10
sheets but what if you had hundreds of
sheets right so in that scenario you
might prefer using parameters because
once you set the parameter you can use
that particular parameter for all the
sheets in your visualization and even
you can use these parameters in your
dashboards as well so I think this was a
little simpler to understand now what
are the use cases that we will be
discussing today in parameters
so there are multiple parameters that
you can use in your day-to-day W usage
so we'll learn the most frequently used
parameters we're going to use the top
end parameters date field parameter
Dynamic measures Dynamic Dimensions
Dynamic measures and dimensions
reference lines and some sets so I hope
so far so good now let's begin with a
practical session so let's get back to W
so we'll be using the superstore data
set we have dates and etc etc columns
which we need for the parameters to be
applied so we'll go with that
so you can see that I've already worked
on some sheets which include the
parameters such as date parameter
Dynamic measures Dynamic Dimensions
Dynamic measures and dimensions
etc etc
so don't worry I'll save this book for
your future reference we'll be creating
new sheets and we'll be applying new
parameters for a better understanding in
a practical way
so for now let's create a new sheet
so you can see the icon by clicking that
you can just enter into the new sheet
now for our reference let's rename it so
we'll rename it as top
and so we'll be beginning with the top n
parameters so we'll rename it as top
info now enter
here
so for top n let's drag
sales into rows
and
subcategory from Dimensions to columns
now we have a bar chart on our screen
let's kind of twist it or change the
orientation yeah now we want to find the
top 10 or top five uh items which are
giving as a top sale so let's kind
afford written descending to do so or to
know the top 10 items which are given as
the maximum sales will apply filters
onto it so to apply a filter let's drag
the subcategory into filters
and you can see uh drop down menu or a
dialog box where we can find the option
called top so here we can specify the
top IDs or top items or top categories
whatever it is which are giving us the
top sales
so we'll be selecting by field and
inside that we have a top 10
now okay we are not going to create a
parameter right away
yeah we have to create a parameter right
away
now just select
a new name for your parameter
now let's select uh
Dot N
parameter
hyphen or let's place the number in the
starting for arbitrary identification
okay
now let's select list
now we have
if you remember we had the minimum and
maximum values as 1 to 100 in the
previous dialog box now let's select
that to then
and here five
or seven
now let's select uh
let's do it 15
and 5. now let's rename them
display as
top 15 Now display the 10 as
top 10 and the 5 as
top 5. now the parameter is created you
can see the number second top and
parameter on my parameters section over
here in the bottom left corner
now the aggregation is sum by default
now let's select apply and okay
now let us right click the parameter and
select the show parameter icon
and here we have the top 15. now let's
try to select top 10. now you can see
that the sheet has changed the data now
we just have the top 10 subcategory
items which are providing us the maximum
number of sales
now if we kind of select a label and
show marked labels then we have the
numbers right you can see the numbers
which are providing as maximum sales
over here
now let's kind of select top five here
so that's how the top and parameters
Works in real time now let's continue
with the next type of parameter in our
list which happens to be the date field
parameter
for that let's create a new sheet now
let's rename it as date sheet
for our reference
now we have the date sheet over here
Now to create a date parameter we need a
date so we have the order date over here
let's drag that to rows
so now let's select
um
profit and let's drop it down to here
now we have the profit on a particular
dates over here
Now to create a date parameter let's
select the icon over here and we have a
create parameter option now let's create
a parameter
now let's rename it as
second hyphen date parameter
I am renaming it as second hyphen
because we have already worked on this
particular sheet and if you have seen
this particular parameter section we
have a date parameter already existing
in my sheet so for that I'm renaming it
as second date parameter for the
reference now we might have a doubt
about selecting the data type for the
dates I'll go with string over here now
let's select the list and add the values
now for a date we have here
as well as quarter
next we'll have months
we'll have a week and we'll also have a
date
so that's our parameter which is number
two date parameter let's select ok so
once we have created the date parameter
the next step is to create a calculated
field so this particular calculation
field will help us with the calculation
of days quarters months weeks and years
now let's rename this as well
rename it as to date
calculation
yep
now in this particular tray we'll be
writing the formula you can see that we
already have a date calculation over
here let's try to see the formula over
there
so here we are we have the date
parameter and here quarter month weekend
daily
and we have the order date parameter
over here or the date and this
particular hyphen queue is used for
dividing the ear into quarters now we're
going to use the same formula
now let's create a new calculated field
now let's select case
and remember the date parameter we
created in the parameter section you
need to drag that in
so that's dragged now let's paste the
formula
and and
so there you go we have the parameter
dragged into the calculation field and
we have the calculation for year quarter
month weekend day and we have the
calculation is valid notification over
here now let's just select ok
now they go in
in the measure segment or
yeah
yeah there you go in the dimension
segment we have the date calculation
field available
okay now we have the sales and aovis
data over here let's change the type of
graph to bar graph
let's change the orientation
yeah
now let's select the label option to
provide us the details of sales
and there you go you have the sales now
let's select the date parameter show
parameter option and we have the ERI
sales now let's select that to quarter
so the parameters is shown on the right
hand column so you can see the sales are
according to here now when you select
quarter you have the quarters when you
select month you have month wise sales
and when you have week week wise sales
and finally the device sales
so you can see that on the 18th of March
2014 we have the maximum amount of sales
so that's how you do it now moving ahead
we have the dynamic measures and dynamic
Dimensions once we are done with the
dynamic measures and dimensions we'll
also execute Dynamic measures and
dimensions together then we'll continue
with reference lines and sets let's get
back to table so what exactly are
Dynamic Dimensions so you can see that
on the left hand column we have so many
dimensions over here so we'll be
creating a filter and we'll be passing
all the dimensions or the number of
Dimensions what we want on our filter to
be so we'll pass those number of
Dimensions into the filter and for the
same we'll be creating a parameter and
we'll be running all the values of
Dimensions through that parameter now
let's go ahead and create a new
parameter let's select the icon create a
parameter and now we are in the new
workbook to avoid confusion so we'll
rename this as
dynamic
dimensions
parameter
we'll select the data type as string
current value
and list and inside the list let's write
in the category shift mode and segment
let's select OK and you can see that we
have the new parameter over here which
says Dynamic Dimensions parameter
now once the uh parameter is created the
next step is to create a calculation
field let's select the calculated field
option and inside this let's rename this
calculation as
dynamic
Dimension calculation field
and inside the tree let's write in the
formula
now let's write in case
and let's track the newly created
parameter
and now
let's select one
category
then
from dimensions
followed by that one
shift mode
then
ship mode
from dimensions
followed by that when
segment
then
segment from dimensions
now and
yeah the calculation is valid let's
apply
okay so you can see that we have a newly
created Dynamic Dimension calculation in
the dimensions section
now we have the newly created Dimension
calculation here we'll drag that to
columns now let's drag sales
to rows
now let's drag the category to columns
so there you go we have the different
categories Furniture office technology
now we have the parameter displayed on
the right hand side now let's select
according to the ship mode so according
to the ship mode we have the first class
second class same day standard class etc
etc and these are the categories
happening in that particular Fields And
if you select the category or parameter
by segment we have these results
consumer corporate and office now this
is how the dynamic Dimension parameter
works now let's get into the dynamic
measure parameter
for that let's create a new sheet we are
in the new sheet now
now Dynamic measures are completely same
to Dynamic Dimensions the only thing
changing here is instead of Dimensions
we'll be dealing with measures now we'll
follow the same steps again first create
a
parameter
let's rename this as
dynamic
measures parameter
and in the list we'll be using sales
profit and quantity
let's select OK and that parameter is
done now let's create a calculated field
similar to Dynamic dimensions
let's rename this calculation is dynamic
measures calculation
and inside the tray let's type in case
let's drag the measures parameter
there you go
now
when
we have used sales profit and quantity
so sales
then
sales
when
profit
then
when quantity
quantity
and
yeah the calculation field is valid
apply and okay
now let's make use of show parameter
option so that we can see the parameter
on the right hand corner
now let's select the category from
dimensions
and the newly created Dynamic measures
calculation onto rows
so we have the
bar chart over here
now let's select profit so you can see
the profit by
category wise and you can select the
label so that we can have a clear
picture of the numbers
now if we select the quantity we have
the details according to the quantity
now to just make things here look a
little better we can drop the category
off and make use of sub category to have
a better visualization on the
subcategories which are bringing as
maximum sales you can rearrange them in
descending order and we can see
binders are giving us maximum profit uh
in the number of quantity in the profit
yeah copiers and in sales we have phones
so that's how we use Dynamic measures in
real now the next part is both Dynamic
measures and dynamic Dimensions together
for that all you need to do is just
select the calculations from Dynamic
measures and drop it down to rows and
dynamic measure Dimension calculations
onto columns we're using both the
calculations together and now let's kind
of use the option of show parameter
where we can see the dynamic Dimension
parameter and dynamic measure parameter
together now when you select category
and sales quantity
now we have both dimensions and measures
here
now let's select the label option so
that we can have a detailed
appearance on numbers now we have the
segments over here consumer corporate
and office when we select sales we have
the sales number when we select profit
we have the profit number when we have
the quantity we have the quantity number
so that's how the dynamic dimensions and
dynamic measures are used in real time
so the next parameter that we'll be
dealing with is the reference lines
now we are back on Tableau let's create
a new sheet
now for reference line let's select the
order date
and drop it down to columns and let's
select sales from measures and drop it
down to rows now let's make a change to
here we'll we'll check that today and we
have a line over here
we need the sales and continuous day
format yeah so this is how it looks like
now let's create a new parameter
let's rename this as
date parameter
let's select the data type as date and
current value
and let's select the date as
so according to data set we have the
dates between 2013 to 2018 so select
anything between 2013 to 14.
let's select 2014. yeah now let's select
okay
so now we have the newly created date
parameter over here let's select the
issue parameter icon now let's get back
to analytics and try to use a line so
we'll use a reference line let's select
table
let's select the type of line
and color
okay
so you can see a reference line over
here which is got created
now let's get back to data once and date
parameter let's edit it once I think we
forgot something important
it's fine here
let's recreate the line again let's use
the reference line table
and here we created a date parameter we
need to select this I think I forgot
that
okay now let's select the type of line
let's select a medium thick line and
dotted line let's select the color as
pink
yeah that should be it let's select okay
now let's select the show parameter
option when we have the date parameter
option over here let's kind of change
the date and once we change the date you
can see there is a shift in the line
so that's how we use the reference line
in real time we have the date parameter
over here this is how we use it now
let's move on to the next option or next
parameter in the list that is the set
parameter for that let's create a new
sheet
now let's drag the sales to columns
and subcategories to rows
now select subcategory and
yeah let's select subcategory from
Dimensions right click and let's use the
create option and from there we'll be
creating a set
let's rename this set the subcategory